all right and I believe we are live
what's up everybody I believe what's up
everybody and welcome to episode 116 of
the iron Lords podcast I am your host
least for a little while no head
sovereign while the boss Lord kognito
makes his way back from Guardian Council
he'll be joining us shortly in addition
to Lord addict who seems to be m.i.a
right now but you know that's an addict
thing so yeah although King says he has
been getting here on my own for me I
have to apologize for my absence you
know something cannot be avoided but I'm
glad to be back in the round chillin and
of course Lord kognito first thing says
oh yeah I need you to hold me down while
I get back from Guardian kind of like
damn you he actually fly me like right
now he's home chilling he's listening
let me see let me see what they do
guys no they gave us the option last
week of me and etic doing the show alone
yeah I'm be honest we need to make that
a patreon tier we need the whole God
that needs to happen that is oh never
wreck I wanna see how this listen if you
ever want the podcast is definitely
never show up again I tell you right now
do not let me and that be this is me
that do need to do that's me in the hot
tub talking about helicopters is above
we all know what's going on we gots to
get out of here I'm telling you like me
and I do
we've got a crazy I don't want that
should be a new $5,000 podcast planet
that's what you were no more IOT we got
the boss on his way
we had the young wolf on his way so
let's just talk to our special guest you
know no offense now lord pete AKA snail
dough the boss of LPS amazing stream
team and of course the lord of ban
hammers great and small opposed what's
going on i heard you guys are gonna uh
you know how about we needed help
yes I am I am the emergency chute so to
speak definitely a bulletin chamber not
much man and busy been busy with doing a
bunch of our you know first look videos
got a couple more in the in the
background that I'm editing what we're
doing some stuff and then I've been
doing division two pretty hard with my
with my raid team we finally got the
boss down on Friday man that thing that
last boss if you take your time we were
in there for 16 17 minutes she was just
doing that last boss and it was all I
never felt that that excitement's smell
no no why you be trying to call that
joins rains
I mean I'm just I gotta go this
conversation because why are they not
raged what makes them different
they're not like little instances that
they stretch out they just make they
just like take regular enemies and let's
let's give them extra shields like true
there's a lot there's no it's not
because there's a lot of mechanics
there's a lot of mechanics and things
you need to do a lot of coordination I
mean I have a bunch of videos up on my
YouTube page of articles and you know
what I'm telling you that's stuff if you
go in there and you don't have a clue
what's going on like most people did the
first week like I did the first week
there is no way you can do anything but
when they did that when they say they
had raids when they were they just the
incursions right that didn't count that
those are just extra dungeons yeah these
are raids listen I'm not really gonna go
out the game like that cuz actually you
like the game what I was saying is like
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
um going and coming from where you know
we play World of Warcraft with is real
raids like cuz I laugh a destiny raids
when you be like oh yeah you know we are
here doing this raid you a little
six-man team shut up like that ain't
really no rate what you're doing is
doing a high kick I'm high mechanic
instance that's what you're doing like a
super nightfall basically what it is
with a boss here is it going through and
you getting loot when we talking about
rage you're talking about 30 dudes Jets
are mages there's a buff and pull the
the warriors and you know you understand
like the level of raids is like that's a
rate when there's a hundred people going
in the tackle is one boss that you can't
get it done unless you got 7080 boots
yeah but you're talking you're talking
to me you're talking to a person it's a
classic Raider from Warcraft
oh yeah any person group you know
fighting the dragons and then world
bosses and having to fight horde and to
have to fight other Alliance kills to
take a kill I mean I've been there for
those hardcore raids and I've been here
who these new types of raids and I will
tell you that this kill I have not felt
you know that pleasure and enjoyment as
a kill since back in black temple when
we downed Illidan
that's how much enjoyment I got because
it was that difficult because the group
of people I'm working with they did as
much hard work as I did and we were in
there probably three four nights a week
for two to three hours trying to take
down bosses get everybody gear and
everything to make everything easier
because you had gear sets that'll buff
your groups and things like that so they
have those dynamics in there that you
know that are super helpful they're not
necessary but they are super helpful for
you know the average or above-average
game players that are playing because
the normal people out there like that
aren't gonna know those mechanics
there's no way they're gonna do anything
yeah yeah I understand I was just you
know like for a lot of people that don't
know that the vision to have their form
of a raid there everybody has their own
take on what they would see or perceive
a raid to be and then you know we also
have limitations with these systems
these systems don't allow us to do a
World of Warcraft type of situation yeah
we will love that Stadium man like that
stuff is in the cloud you're gonna be
able to and I don't know how well it's
gonna work but you will be seeing like
thousand people raised like no idea
Soglin I really don't think so and this
isn't gold anyway right the reason why I
don't really ever see us moving to that
area that type of area because the pure
horsepower on a PC is completely
different now you telling me telling us
that these guys is going to offload some
form of workstation from our main
computing you know unit whatever the
PlayStation 5 and whatever the Xbox
follow will become right if we're all
floating I think that's when we go into
problems so I really think everything
has to be done from that main station so
that's why I think the CPU is more
important than the graphical processor
because I believe the graphical process
and the X is more than capable I just
thought the CPU was definitely not up to
standard that Jaguar stuff was
definitely not up yeah just just just
milking those those cores and trying to
make them a little faster
I mean again it's like it's a patch
right it's not it's not what you really
want right you need those cores to be
much faster to be able to handle that
CPU intensive stuff so I mean obviously
Scala is gonna take us to that level
hopefully oh okay I just noticed and I
don't really look at the two super kings
shut up and give you somebody posted
that they wanna hang out with me on
destiny listen let me tell you something
when I get in in the morning I get in
probably like around five o'clock I'm on
destiny
alright and then when one o'clock in the
afternoon will come I'm still on destiny
and then when you know three o'clock in
the afternoon rolls around
I'm still on destiny so if you and my
friends let's just add me get up with me
and I'm on destiny so I'm running raids
I'm running night falls I'm running
strikes and running with young Chris I'm
running with hot monkeys on run with
Mason I'm running with everybody if
you're armed we are and then we're in
the party's not don't get it twisted
that king that you see here the PG King
is not available right we're if you want
to get into a jet please do not be
easily offended because you just gonna
leave and be mad like he's not who he is
on TV no I'm definitely not so get in
there have a good time see Buono Buono
100% we are out of control in that room
trust me that's why we can't have no me
at it just now if you have the patreon
only episode after dark amber Lords
inner light Lords so with that let's
give our man his proper official
introduction we got the incredible hunk
of the ILP Oh
the king of all statues after that all
combat talk ooh oh we gotta talk the
creator of the fraud alert movement
I can't David ogw Jonny bones Jones is
out here taking up the most dangerous
fighters that you could probably take
out and what did you think I mean I felt
I felt he played it a little safe but he
needed to because this is a Thiago
Santos is a dude who is super dangerous
swinging at any point in time he could
drop you with either his legs or his
hands and Santos I'ma be honest with you
I was surprised pleasantly surprised
that he fought a strategic fight he was
in the pocket all the time he was he was
countering John he was going after John
but at the same time he wasn't wiling
out throwing punches and kicks like I
thought he would other leg oh I know
right now John holy guy ice he was
rocking I gotta give it to ya' go Santos
I got I get what makes Bones difficult
bones of the dude that he can fight you
a trained zero Andrew no matter it no
matter how you know he's very
long-limbed you would think that
smothering him works but John could kick
you with a Sobotka to the head and zero
so it's still tough and he's constantly
throwing his hands in your face trying
to try to kind of deter whatever you're
doing and he's just you don't often talk
about how great his defense is John's
defenses off the frickin charts man
everything is ranked zero he doesn't
even need to use his length and when he
does it's it's it's a walk in the park
so he stood there with Thiago he smiled
he caught some stuff he hit he got hit
with some
mmm it was a good fight I think John's I
would have liked to have seen John try
to take him down because I think the
split decision you know you haven't you
have a judge that wasn't feeling John's
way of fighting on the other way you
could have lost the title so you know I
wish he had been a little more
aggressive but I think the fight was
good for both of them I think Thiago
Santos
he upped is uh he upped his value with
that fight so it was a good main event
before we get let's talk about these
ladies and I gotta say girls women women
man the lioness man Amanda newness is a
freaking beast man I is one thing about
Holly Holm that I never liked about the
way that she fights her fight style is
very like when she she jabs he doesn't
necessarily jab with purpose he just
jabbed as a feeler everything out there
so what happens is when you get into
that rhythm of throwing stuff out just
as a feeler that's something that could
be timed yeah exactly what she did she
timed those feelings ABS that are
nothing jabs and she caught her with us
the same savate kick that Holly Holm Kos
Ronda Rousey where she caught a flushing
the mop listen and this is what I'm
saying with that right um watching the
fight and Holly Holmes doesn't punch
through the target so like when you try
to punch this hostile is is better for
Ronda Rousey yeah Ronda Rousey really
couldn't fight as well as y'all thought
she could fight she really couldn't
fight she can in her on her feet she's a
fraud right but on that ground she'd get
that arm and knocking Nora out there
take that arm out in his gone so and
that's what she trains to do get that
arm ball and make him submit pop it out
the socket right now when she's on her
feet her hand game is garbage Holly
Holm's hand game and her foot game is
decent reason why man the Nunez was able
to time her walk to her
because she punches with purpose yep
every shot that she was throwing at her
she was trying to knock her out cold
every shot so when I saw it I was like
oh man is gonna come in I can honestly
tell that she's setting up for the kick
to the head and then the thing is the
way she pounces as soon as she got her
little bit off her squabble
that was all and she pounced and that
was it and the thing is at first I
thought the ref stopped it fast but then
when she tried to stand up and she
couldn't and she was just falling
backwards I said okay okay that was a
good style yeah you see the eyes rolling
in and that was that and that was that
so again I don't know again Holly Holm
she I mean she trains with with bones
his team she sees in that gym like the
thing is again I was like you said she
doesn't punch through the target her
style is very sort of elusive and
throwing out a lot of feel of jabs and
we're not looking for the big shot but
again when you have that sort of rhythm
when you fight it's very time about that
comes from her kickboxing background
exactly yeah I did 12 round and 9 round
crap that's where that comes from
it's when you are brought up in MMA from
the ground up you're taught that's
remember you just you just said the
pouncing right the management pouncing
that comes from you engaged in this
activity you wasn't transplanted from
kickboxing out of boxing that you have
to you know range time and work the
clock and work movement you know set up
a jab know an MMA it's all about the
bang bang boogie yeah real quick so if
you got that striking you can get low
you can take them to the ground you want
to get in and get out with is least
damage to yourself as possible and
talking about least damage as possible
yeah boy oh man listen after after Ben
Askren is questionable submission of
Robbie Lawler you know I mean I
we saw some holes I've been asking it to
always been the dude is like look if you
get you on the ground is over no matter
what situation no matter what the case
it's a rap and I
proved true like Bennett he's a beast on
the ground but when it comes to the
stand-up game yeah there's some holes
there and Robbie Lawler exposed that
that got baby that guy here I don't care
what nobody say you're not coming in
with the sloppy six-pack you can't do
that he always he always looks like he's
like he's like Archie from like you know
Oh Jack it looks like you're like drugs
but he went in yeah dude mouths word all
on him were going at it this was this
was one of those real grudge matches and
monster doll just came in he took his
chance on a flying knee and he knows
like Aspen is a wrestler he but he was
the cinnamon yeah yeah but his instinct
is to duck and he ducked right into a
knee right into the temple the dude was
out he got actually Maz Vidale got he
got jerked like three seconds like it
really is a two second knockout he was
out the moment he got hit it was a wrap
it's just the ref could not get to him
in time to call him yeah this is what
happens right he he knew he was going
for the shoot that's all he has so if he
can give the double leg takedown and he
want to grind it out like he said you
want to put his head into my crotch and
grind it out and do all listen he knew
at the end of the night he said it was
always in his back pocket that that knee
was available at any time when he goes
to shoot your head is down the reason
why your head is down it cuz you can't
punch a guy in the back of the head
right that's automatic fragrant right so
you guys pretty much cool unless you can
snuff him from the side or the left side
right right right now your instincts is
not to throw left or right if somebody's
coming at you your instincts is to back
up and the punch down so he he what he
trained his mind to do was when he ducks
in throw the knee yep his face is like a
wild uppercut it is okay and he caught
it flush I mean again with that you you
don't know if it's gonna hit right
because you jump up it's one of those
things that you can never tell exactly
where it's gonna hit it
called him right on the temple uh-huh it
was like oh and then he bounced his head
off the cameras a few more doctrine with
- it was totally unnecessary but again
you just you don't know so you keep
attacking but man dude man I mean I know
he's gonna want to run that one back you
know don't I don't know no one no one
but when when you wake up in the
ambulance and you say yeah well I'm
ready
you don't want to run that back you
can't let Bosworth all walk around with
that one beast and he's got a much
better he's continued to get better eat
my husband the Beast at first okay this
is me being a fraudulent guys I don't
know crap about enemy right I just know
big name dude
I just know big ring do it right so when
I when I catch a new do coming in I
looked at his backstory I do the
backstory check and then I see his come
up I like his mannerisms and then I like
what he said after the fight he said yo
listen man be honest what y'all wanted
to beat the hell out of him for 14 min
or we right at the right I know you were
having some drinks while you enjoy up
late check out the many checks Cuban
Jesus was going on now you see I like
the fact that he he plays to the crowd
he told him he said listen I'm about
these checks on mine I'm trying to save
as much money as possible I'm trying to
get another fight as soon as possible
because I took absolutely zero damage
this is a fact you win in there you gave
him that flying needed a head blew his
brains out pause great game the
double-double and it had to count them
out with the fastest knockout Dana White
I'm not gonna lie at that moment he had
a man gasm
oh yeah he he can't stand been on a
level of you
you you want to talk about somebody
buying somebody to set somebody up so
they can die like he actively went out
or quiet this big mouth idiot and he
hated hangout would another do that he
hates those two dudes and fights so they
can die actively and when this happen
Dana White never took the podium with
such a demeanor such a smile such a glow
like it's over you for the rest of your
life I've never seen him so happy in the
ring that is so you know he's supposed
to be objective and just coming good job
whatever he you can see in his face you
know see there is man I I'm gonna tell
you right now see all right Disney the
$2 super Jack King Olav means that been
a screw got yeah yeah you're dizzy your
knees in the box - so cog what did you
think
back in yeah bloody job the joint out
he's buggin right now my job our job
maybe I can't so I'm going on with your
account happening yeah is buggin about
me I'm real quick yeah that John's crazy
fight was crazy now I mean I couldn't
even envision anything like that like
that like you told me you know - these
guys match up ten times and that's what
happened like nah like we was blowing
shout at the khakis I was in there with
him child it's a clowns I was up in
there man arms and stuff and myelin
games reason enjoy it
so I'm sitting I'm like look miles but
I'll gonna come out but then gonna get a
hold of them you understand and then
when it went down and like you ever seen
like when rigor mortis get oh yeah I
gotta talk about that cuz I go blow
because I know arm shot the far shot the
mess there I supposed to do they fight
all coaches Oh eat with it because farce
very upset
and I said look I made the other way
like meds is like for me like I'm from
that joint King we know like when dudes
get stretched and these are them crunch
man you know say like don't be like it
affects is or if your mouth was loose
prior yeah bets is off
you know I'm say and it turns credit
like the rest was to get him and get him
already yeah for him to do all too fast
oh no no I know it went just like this
they said they'd let him walk around the
ring after the fact instead of holding
into a corner so I let him walk around
no talk to boys no fun you know what it
is though that's the level I hate people
have we smoked pause beam head stop man
in the crowd right now all that lip
service you are not giving my man's
service listen I love this do so much
throw their hands over bagels
all-american bagel and he wants
all-american bagel you gonna give up
that game I do I'm about to go you know
Nick just angling not a fight that that
fight to me that just that made the
night like I've never seen anything like
that that they're right I've never seen
him so I don't I put it this way be I
don't even know if you come back off
that like I'm like like you know I was
someone stock takes a hit so might not
be the thing like you got smashed in
five seconds like it's really two
seconds because it took ref three
seconds go
you know what happened I could see this
right there you go in in that what
you're saying is like we all know like
well in a boxing world your back world
if
do get a flash knockout he can angle at
any type of way right now when a do gets
a tail smoking for 12 rounds late if Ben
would have got a tail smoking for those
14 minutes that this do we want to give
him but he's pretty gave and then at the
end of the 14 capital with the cherry on
top like that that's different I think
you know is too many angles you can play
like your I didn't see the knee I'd dip
to the left my foots left you know who
got a good shot I wanna run it back I
don't ever think he's gonna run that
back though is is his stock that's a
yeah it's almost it's almost worse I'm
solved than when Connor did although is
like it was just so devastating and and
he it's like they race you so when they
walked him out like a sea of gold like
that's when you get snuffed right
nothing you don't know what happened
that's what here here the who did that
look shout out to the who did that for
you listen I want to hit up a couple of
people right because I had people
running around with my verbage like I
had people talking about Xbox
only-begotten son Phil Spencer shout-out
to you frost that's not giving me my
credit because all you fools out there
was not repping old boy all right I
really wanted at a hundred percent right
and I know you see I want you to go to
your favorite because it's one of your
favorite shows right that's on youtube
right now that gets the 300 and 600 K
use those dudes your sad thing you did a
little expose on Phil Spencer to savior
to Xbox boy stop playing those games
with me there you go with that Batman
like that Batman so anybody showed they
wanted to go in on old Phil fine
give him time I'm down with xbox only
begotten Son I was only one calling Xbox
only begotten Son the Messiah of Xbox
whatever it was cuz we use in the bushes
then all I'm waiting for is s show
to say in the bushes and I'm at the
corner yeah it was good fights man that
car was sick I know you already talked
about that stuff amazing card man but
who I'm talkin it cuz Tsavo you knows
I'm no addict do you hear me sir yeah
I've been here the whole time
the young go for the ILP the difficult
game conquer and the man with the most
epic and breathtaking beard ever in the
history 300 AD sup brother what's going
on nothing much just got back from
getting my truck oh no I'm still not
mobile let's not get that to us TRUCKING
get you up it's one of those trucks that
have a rope you know I have a skateboard
behind what you complainin uh-huh I can
play that some switch I played a lot of
bleeding edge when uh that little beta
had Thursday out flow
what did you have I like it I'm but I'm
a huge fan of overwatch so you know I'm
naturally gonna drift towards gameplay
like that yeah I mean I know it's a
short amount of time since we played
that at e3 but was there anything that
you saw that was changed not you're
pretty much the same game okay I didn't
get a chance to play it during the Alpha
what did they how did they set it up in
terms of like just I didn't see the game
mode that we played they it so it looks
like they're switching up the maps okay
every week I don't know if it's
character because it's every Thursday
okay so you know I was trying out I was
trying out the the one that called Neto
used at e3 and I was thinking oh so and
if I would have used
knocking we would have won that game
broken the ninja the Beasties any of you
guys or anyway
hit me up and he's like yo what's up but
when I get home from e3 I take my e3
book bags with all that swag and stuff
like that I probably don't get into my
swag until probably like two months
later I'm going through videos and stuff
like that put on videos up and really
trying to decompress from e3 shout out
to mr. boomstick and you know he said to
he said are we feeling like I don't know
it's like you know two weeks behind in
the game at the but I use it on myself
will you let me know when I'm fraud
non-disney ticularly shake-a-lator on
with that let us
segue to the boss now - return from
Guardian God that shinobi gaming ninja
also I'll peel or cutting it what's up
good guest our host special guest one
thing I want to do how you gonna be
posting on my visas and don't put price
tags and say you ain't ready for none of
my items except King Joe oh is that just
like green ders like it's kind of like a
bungee juice iam kind of thing oh yeah
yeah it's not really like no I mean
these I didn't go actively pursuing
deceit price tag you know there's a
number stations could have been had yeah
were they legit or they like free
printed legit bro don't you those they
know everything I mean - yo that car oh
hell I'll savor the Cuban Jesus I'm
better at gears than he is how is that
met now but not real soft man yo shout
out the Guardian comment like it was to
be real which I like hobo's they would
come back today it was so amazing like
what they did for the community oh
absolutely it seemed like that they
really are I wonder what people are not
understanding I saw when yo a little in
a rinky-dink tree I saw it I saw when
your came from you know to come up yeah
so this used to call this wet Kong
because it first started like a little
ball little ball and in Tampa right yeah
I think we didn't expand it to the joint
that I mean he bought his first met four
years ago was on Tampa Bay fairgrounds
kind of little rundown
Stadium kind of a deal hard floor but it
was all about you know people just there
with the content creators and talking
everybody but this is a resort like this
is all-inclusive island where you don't
gotta leave like everything you want
everything your heart desire is there
and it could swallow too many taxes if
it want like your to paksas in this
place it's out of control like the sheer
scale like if you take a look at the
picture I think CJ Gibson had a picture
up of it of just like part of it
literally look like bigger than the
Leviathan is like is getting so big
because you had yet your destiny with
the Guardian card you had warframe with
the tunnel
conjoint you had Borderlands 3 in it it
is so it's not just destiny think if you
don't like destiny you still good
pinball machines and before you even get
it get it got like a vintage arcade cane
tight giant yeah it is really amazing
check out I got stuff coming up right
now in Lawrence the gaming dotnet shot
the dizzy shot everybody we gonna be
putting out a lot of content they know
frag did he said forty a raise for a
million off but for st. Jude's charity
for million alone so this is the new
wave you know I met so many people
obviously you saw he bonds as we linked
up and it was just crazy man it's tough
it's I'm not gonna for it's probably the
most fun con I've been to and you know
what we've done this year you know I'm
saying yeah I'm not seeing like
spectacle of course III is the Superbowl
you know that past intimate thing with
the devs but as far as fun for you to go
I can you go go crazy
look at me right in your face right now
like I'm setting up Germany I'm setting
up Japan of home there's no way I could
slide that under the radar so this is my
little resort getaway Poconos but now I
was a man was late but y'all ready now
man same old stuff you already know and
you're just getting back to it man happy
to be back we missed the week so we got
to get back to it and I didn't do kos
this week because I said you know what
mm I usually do a kos and they'll leave
the statue up for the people that didn't
get it as a CA kos and yeah I never got
a chance to see her man yeah I never got
a chance to see all dynamic that poses
sickening you got the jewels go yo I'm
gonna tell you right now go to Lourdes
is the game and dad met after this go
check out the bio on there Oh mark
that's a great statue man
so that like work with college I mean I
know love for the community today any
tidbits about what's to come oh no they
had they had the new shadow arm key
trailer they showed man who stood out to
the big show he was there long if you
want a lot of stuff shots a car on the
block making man noise right now know
what that's about
but um anyway yo sorry just click on my
jacket you gotta just focus on me so you
could take it off me well um anyway so
like I say yeah they had that they
showed the new warframe joint they
didn't go too deep with the destiny
stuff the vibe I got it was just they
want to do the teaser and they had the
actress that played eros okay and I'm
saying so she was there
so again little teaser shadow key but it
was more like talking to the desert
thing that was dog what they did was
that like any complaint you got with
destiny they put themselves on the
firing squad then had to DS you had the
raid leader they had together
they was like what did we do right with
seasons because basically they could say
yo we going away from expansions it's
definitely season seasons because
they're looking at apex and all these
other games so the whole thing now is
like okay if we're doing this what did
you like about it
what you don't and they let
you go up to the mic King and spit your
boss to them like yo I don't like this
what's going on this that other and your
girlfriend was mad constructive me and
DS chopped it up you know I was attic
you'll love you had I sat down with the
raid leader producer and I was just
telling us like learn their hotel
Leviathan yeah yeah I talked about that
I talked about narrative continuity how
was dope about Kings Falls you played a
campaign eat you into the raid and it's
a story the same thing last wish you
play like we don't like these one-offs
where you fighting the boss you don't
know why you fighting them you know I'm
saying so she was like yeah I did a
little video yeah I got her on video but
we don't get her in the show little much
a lot of times were you able to record
yes full record is no restricting one
time they got a restriction where they
take your phone away
Oh for the cooler yeah they do this Rose
session I can have a cameraman which you
whatever because I noticed like a lot of
the footage right then I like you had
the joint the camera and then you had
your mic because you sound Claire you
sound great
um so like my thing was you needed a
team with you because what I'm trying to
do like addicts say you want to go
whatever and stuff like that but usually
like let me break it down to you guys
when we go to these shows and snow those
days now though is definitely very
meticulous when it comes to and stuff
like that and I really like that I
really like the fact that he brings that
type of meticulous nature to things to
allow you to see and how you supposed to
set up a shot and get that interview out
and it when I was looking I was like man
look like colleges need that that that
that we wanna kill you like this we can
get her to that interview and even
though all the footage was great I know
now you had to get that squad to go so
no I'm working on attic right now Lucas
now the like meta taxes on lock I'm gay
yes I was yes I was and there's no way
to check they trip good are you still
spending a lot of time in doctors
offices the past couple of weeks so I'm
yeah I've been on a switch but I got
that married Omega 2 there's too much
like for you no I mean I don't care
about creating anything I rather this
download levels to see what craziness
people call it people come up with you
yeah yeah beyond I try to I try to get
kids mood to play that and play some of
those downloaded levels but uh he didn't
want none of that smoke thing that is
for the hardcore Mario dude if you want
to pull your hair out playing Mario go
right ahead that's narrow maker yeah we
got bills to pay fellas out unfortunate
because of three mm I
since we had we didn't do June's patreon
so really you a double dose of goodness
all right so we're gonna get into that
right now real quick all right so first
of all let me just give our shoutouts to
all our patrons again thank you very
much guys for domain names I swear man
why people don't say first wants to do
that I've never seen a white person all
right so first we're gonna go with the
demand in the in the chat right now talk
a lot of UFC smack my man I coach a
podcast Mondays sorry I'm there
oh no doubt no doubt and of course one
love always to offer ever patron and
friend Lord Cory lighting a cake no
doubt and of course Lord slow-mo back
slap my lord Hakeem and PC fellow
YouTube brethren Lord Nintendo Direct
that oh I get him back on the show it's
been a minute I need some swish love
yeah laws he promised led to talk about
intended rate the Emperor thank you
yeah yeah wraithers new thanks for being
in a row and a couple of but again since
we haven't been we haven't been
announcing yeah it's been a minute so
thank you though thank you and of course
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
no bill yeah I'm not gonna front you got
some special you cover my do you don't
know like I'm right you know how when
somebody in a bag like any mixing up a
potion I'm like no and of course big
salute to our first patron ever Lord
Michael Lugo aka monkey punch or punch
hey what you meant
I miss you shooting me in the back of
the head pose no we was playing pub gee
the team killed every game playing state
of the game installed Oh driving most
memorable stated it came on what I had
is one mean kid smooth were playing and
I had a van and kids smooth like there
was like five zombies he this dude
flipped out thought he was gonna die
gret took off with the van blew the van
up and they came back and I was like
dude they're all dead like you you did
all that unnecessary stuff I leave the
white have to make it race some weight
will say he'd been here for a minute
oh my bad great world salute though you
might have changed your name that's what
it is I'll recognize you I don't
I never recognized the yeah but your
name before me Twitter to chat rate
broke slow so that we know continue so
yeah watch them be like this is always
fun never been my name big my bad again
follow Sammy Prescott horse family to
the round Lord j5o bring it down last
week through all of that read bed
slander that all the week before last
because I'm not here away I set up a
schism so everybody agree with me is
that game way too much landed follow my
I guess today Lord snag was torn loves
to the Rome bean
you can't be on the show because you're
the family from the cradle to the grave
Lord ambered himself loaded pixel and of
course by Lord Tao Tao Zi Qi thank you
for support much appreciated and then of
course next we have Lord Jo Hansel Vijay
gasps yes thank you so much I think Jo
Hansel's in the chat and of course
always last but never least from across
the pond Lord death singer all right
another one we got to get on this Pope
Jimenez yeah I get that we're doing
badly that all feel bad we do these
giveaways and we're gonna double up so
we're gonna have when you do in July so
we're gonna do both $10 back to back
then both 20s bags winning today I'll be
okay
go all right so the winner of the first
ten dollar giveaway quiz buttocks
favorite favorite
Lord Emperor oh yeah so the winner now
of the second ten dollar giveaway and PC
you guys pose like that like on it or I
can grats guys I will get that info to
you as soon as possible all right so
these twenty dollar giveaways mm-hmm the
first twenty dollar giveaway Lord stitch
going on is always open to conversation
the winner of the second twenty dollar
giveaway is Tao okay sweetie you better
know day that humbling gives you a hand
oh who won ahead of time like we say
they name is TT spring giveaway oh man
robear's rep your meds you look at that
drip drip it is wag so the winner of the
first tee spring giveaway
yeah and now I know is ring everybody
maybe who said he'll share the wealth
you know yeah no doubt so we're done
with patreon for the past who must thank
you so much again for guys much as we
say everything for us especially being
every Sunday so thank you once again so
let's get into these topics way away
some things have gone down just go right
down the list I'm gonna start with the
boss talked about you got some
PlayStation talk to talk crazy man oh
I'm so yeah shot a 2mp first comm was
kind of one of the first outlets to put
out the information so apparently
there's some exploits going on in the
Sony network and basically it's a major
it's a security exploit and just for the
record it is you know more so on the
network side as opposed to the consoles
I just want to be clear but basically
our works is that like typically like
PSM requires you know the credit card to
supply that CVV number you know extra
little three digits on the back so
usually that's when you on PSN is
something that's requested but when you
log in from a different console that's
where they getting this backdoor exploit
so pretty much you know the thief could
get you know get their hands on it with
someone else's PlayStation user account
and then they can rack up on the credit
card so you know they try to bring it to
the attention of PlayStation obviously
this has been something that's been a
bit of a concern with security issues in
the past I wanted to bring this to the
round with the exploit that we are
hearing and obviously you know you know
it's now supposedly being addressed and
stuff like that but on the consensus is
you know the security people feel away
about security on PSN network so I
British to run what do you guys feel
about this is this something that is you
know you feel is a major issue that
needs to be talked about and or just
something that's so or one-off kind of
situation let's go a king for 2019 and
Yamaha still talking about Oh place this
is the place to play it's just a matter
of time you like one of those guys go to
the gym all the time put your stuff in a
lock and you come back oh yeah
please Station that's how you do that
honey security is they out there smoking
cigarettes in the backyard they don't
care about your stuff and then we call
them out on and you say yo are you
saying that a gym membership has better
security Janice up yes when you call
them up on it you say um excuse me look
at that Sony won't even pay for padlocks
you're courting the key they don't pay
for anything cuz when you tell them
about it did you got five hundred
dollars stole out of your account
that's
on you brah like you know like they
redirect you until the for if you file
with your bank dick banger your PSA for
clarity it's not on the console it can
be hacked for any network so it's
two-factor authentication of some of
that you can protect yourself but I see
what you're going King what obviously
they've they've had a history you know
somebody isn't part of it that it can
bypass a two-factor authentication by
email giving a fake source of make a
fake payment source
in the theory you should be able to stop
it but again it's happening on site on
the networks I'm outside of it as
opposed to on the console side so that
is something that they really need to
stress as far as a major thing I know a
lot of people out other sites use it you
know that kind of things I just never
had this problem of my xbox I mean I'm
just so I just really want to bring it
to the table like sometimes you know
when somebody repeatedly offend you in
this manner somebody needs to talk out
about it and I'm growing this to the
table today because definitely 100% I
needed Christmas I don't know why Chris
is not here today but uh Chris whenever
you show up options bar yeah maybe they
banned you on your Playstation because
you try to get your money back that
Diderot you baby
in theory equals yes I'll just be a fee
I'll try to be fair yeah yeah it could
be got it cuz we got there's no getting
around on this pay the bills real quick
side shout-out to Lord ed sling with the
finally Jack salute Lords missed you
guys last week happy you're back
salute fo Dominus and is Amir does PSN
have security from the windows name oh
sure the brac the rail fill works for
Google's there
no rap do me a favor
post your own your pre-order that just
happened to you verify because I don't I
don't have a Playstation obviously so
it's happening on just the consoles or
where else all that on is it anything
it's using an expert and to explore on
the network so basically these modders
that's what that's what they're
literally doing you don't and so again
it's just racking up trying to get that
CVV information when you're not on
someone else's console it's on another
network it's how they're able to snatch
it so ok so yeah that's just they gotta
fix that I'm sorry that there should be
no reason why anyone should be able to
snatch your security information or take
your payments or anything like that
come on Sony how much money do you have
in your bank account you should be able
to fix this if my company is not nearly
as big as yours and we have dual intent
ocation two-factor authentication and we
don't have problems
you shouldn't have problems you know a
lot of people are saying they spending
all the money on making a one person
experience games that they're not paying
for this game 2014 was a big date on
them we definitely definitely know that
so what do you take addict what's going
on what you meant oh he's in the bushes
[Laughter]
the things that bothered me most about
this is one they knew about it and they
didn't and they knew about it and they
didn't give it the importance that it
deserved at the time so and the fact
that it's on the server side and not the
console side I think it makes it even
more dangerous because like you said
it's not like somebody
stealing your info specifically to
access your console and like you know
running up a thousand dollar bill or
whatever on your console with games and
whatnot it's that they're stealing your
actual full-on information they could do
anything with it they go buy a car with
your information so that to me is what's
most concerning and the fact that they
knew about it and they didn't give it
the importance that it deserved and now
that more people are bringing up their
stories of what's happening with that
now all sudden it's back in the public
eye but this is this is a kind of an
export that they've known about for a
couple years right I don't know Russian
no Russian Xbox probably got hacked they
probably got ddos this weekend but did
anybody get a uber purchased and they
carry more PlayStation account this is
why I'm just trying to figure out what's
going on with these whips with the
police is that like the fact that they
knew about it and if they've been
approached about it about the exploit
you know and you know again as of right
now been looking at the updates you know
obviously they people are showing videos
of how to do the exploit you know what
what is Playstations answer in all of
this as of now I have not seen an
efficient so I'm not saying it does not
exist
oh boy JDK we go if you're fool enough
to trust Sony's network you deserve to
be happy
should be on Xbox Live anyway PSN is a
scrub network should have learned before
look autumn listen you know obviously
again know about the big hack 2014
whatever whatever
since then Yama but keep it 1000 like I
only do PayPal some prepaid car with
them I when you had that exploit where
basically the keys to the front door was
left in front of the house in a box and
are you to go that really put me in a
bad place with them as far as security
now since then yes it's it's improved
but when you hear things like this you
just want them to be a little bit more
responsive a little bit more transparent
again I haven't said that they have not
responded I have not seen anything
officially to this point if you guys
have seen anything please let me know
because I was a Guardian car
but yeah that that's what I'm seeing
right now and as of right now this
update is I mean his article still has
not been updated with any response and
on Sony sighs so that part troubles me a
little bit you know and so that's where
I'm at I don't know I think with them
they just they trying to downplay it
because I guess the reported incidents
having grown to uh the amount where they
have to address it publicly it's you
saying I can go pre-order other systems
and stuff like get into this on the nose
like for me after that I think it was
2011 that it happened earlier than 2014
but you know to me it was just one of
those things like you know what I paid
out with you guys I to fact in my paper
out yeah I put up as many barriers as
possible it's a pain when you make a
purchase especially now as a Isis but
it's worth it man that peace of mind yes
I don't trust him in that regard and
again like and the thing was and it goes
back to that ps3 thing like how do you
put the keys to the front door in the
system I don't care how well you think
you protected it you just don't do that
I know what it sounds like to me guys
it sounds like I got a great restaurant
where the food is banging but you just
can't pay with your credit card you
gotta pay only restaurants and that kind
of sucks in this day and age but some
people don't want to walk around with
all that money yeah no Brad he's like
it's not just with Sony he said banks
get hacked a lot true the only thing is
again it is a network issue but at the
same time because you look at the track
record right you gotta look at the
history this is not the first time
they've been associated with the
security breach so for me personally is
no disrespect to the engineers but I am
NOT putting my hard-and-fast credit card
information saving up on a server I just
can't do it all with them based on it
but all here we go
if I was mark so I would rub this in
Sony's face it would be you buddy how to
share a gay moment he's oh my god if you
think you're bringing your digital games
forward on PSN your games we put forward
to me wha-ha-ha I think for me I mean
and this goes for my coach would intend
oh I I don't I don't put my info on
anything I just
especially the Saudi especially is funny
you say that I do I
to me it's PayPal with area ant factor
between my credit card and it never went
to the account and let me say what does
Xbox do today I went to my account and
say Xbox are you acting out it's not at
a time but I could tell you this that
PlayStation makes me nervous
and I've heard all guys talking about
there's so much stuff going on over
there and this just elevates the point
again it highlights it for all y'all to
see y'all still keep going back over
there they still keep robbing and it's
right it's not something that's robbing
let's let's get it right is the systems
is easy to hacked in the back door
because they cloud infrastructure or the
internet security is terrible so it
allows hackers to get in there and take
care of stuff and all the reason why
that here where Microsoft is a
beneficial deal and hopefully they bring
security when I'm with a couple of more
big guys in there that can keep well out
and touching stuff and I like that I
like that the deal with micro stands is
fantastic I'll go bad again anything to
contribute and panic out of the bushes
what no I'm here okay you back now no
you were not here you in the bushes I
was watched not when we asked you
talking about the security thing yeah
but it's Sony be Sony there's nothing I
can really say I there's been multiple
occasions they they've shown that they
care about their bottom line more than
people getting stolen from
they have on multiple occasions and set
it up like yeah we was in the wrong
here's a refund everything's good like
oh you want your money back then you're
just gonna have to either get your money
back or not play on playstation you
can't add both okay I think I'm better
about that though didn't they make sort
of change in regards to like returning
games and stuff like that and no that is
that that is refund policies that has
nothing I'm talking about here Buster's
shots at JT David bleeping Microsoft
could rub his sonís faces they can't do
it with games rap rap for me I must
defend JT gamer because I began to get
defend yourself but I think game pad
speaks for itself sir pushes oh god the
bracket of building fill it a little
shot that's all I got was we got
something all right so we're gonna say
we write into statics a topic so there's
been some some happenings and remedies
tell us what's going on then so
apparently they're like Microsoft they
effort to my knowledge they didn't own
the the publishing rights or do they own
the IP because it's kind of like
everywhere for for Alan Wake what I've
been told is that they sewed it back to
remedy and that's what it seems like
what actually happened I don't know when
it happened I don't know if I happened
last week last month last year but it
was finally came out that remedy has
secured all of the all of the publishing
rights and everything about that IP and
so I'm a little like I get it fighting
now I go in there in no shadow deaths
ain't gonna find out let's see what Jeff
I don't play good man I have an
exclusive game show system put your card
on PSN and see if you're the lucky one
cross your fingers a lot of employees
right now but you know for what I've
been seeing is okay so if they weren't
gonna do not in the family because it
definitely looked like they wasn't they
they weren't going to outsource they
clearly wasn't gonna by remedy I don't
think they should have bought remedy
anyway but they gave an iconic brand
back to to remedy which is currently
working with Sony well on control you
know it might not be an exclusive but
they have a lot of marketing rights with
them so I'm just like you know now what
could happen is all the way to could
show up on the Saudis thing cuz right
now they have a deal going on with it
and I'm just like you know you're not
bad let's be real here
if next year at e3 Alan will wait to was
teased because you know Sony got no
problem teasing something that's eight
years in the future
they got no problem that game won't even
be in concept they don't even have
concept art about it and though show a
trailer there's nothing to do with the
game because that's what Sony does so do
you think that's gonna be an issue do
you think that they're lighting
opportunities go because I feel like
they had a Mike to draw up moment and
any III all they had to do is announcer
and Alan way too sure it might not have
appealed to the to the many but it would
have posed to the hardcore game a lot of
people like that trash I don't but you
know so I feel like they gave that Mike
the drop moment not only gave it up but
they potentially like someone else their
competitors pick it up
oh do do 15 okay this is from JEP game
for $5 15th studios aren't sitting still
they're making games and they will be
coming soon game pass forever baby best
selling game don't be jealous
look here preppy got a point there that
was kind of we know the truth about
Danny pears what did you ain't got it
like what was it game pass that we don't
understand and listen to you Tommy
that's the last time I'm not gonna be
something
we have accomplished you got him to read
sometimes I just want you know why that
was JD game and JD game with the men on
his planet he out dinner he in the club
like Oh defecating game I gave you
let's go let's go away King first on
this okay so you putting Barry Bonds
first I I got it oh the question is who
really cares about Allen we a lot of
people did Oh shadow day oh it's out the
lugging like it don't let all this
PlayStation nonsense distract you from
the fact the switch is tracks like you
snuffing the kid that has nothing I'm a
dick and I proved that message so like
who really kid I mean a lot of people
saw that you can make Alan Wake and just
rename it as The Blair Witch like we
slaughtered right because I was there
and I was tapping cold I was tapping
everybody to cyber stuff and I was like
oh no Alan wait oh and it hit you with
his The Blair Witch and maybe they felt
that Alan Wake ran its course all this
right maybe they said well we're not
gonna purchase your studio and there's
your consolation prize we give you back
your your most treasured IP we say sell
it back to you so you can do it as you
choose and is that is that them keeping
the bond together with them like we
won't purchase your studio because we're
purchasing all these studios and you
know we evaluated your studio from top
to bottom and um it doesn't fit the
criteria that we're looking for but
instead of just holding on to this IP
we're gonna allow you to get your IP
back so you can do it as you choose so
that studio can actually still thrive
and grow and
died in industry yeah I think see I
think when it comes to Alan Wake people
have like the memory of that game is one
of those like people all we loved that
it was great it was great for its time
on Xbox there was something different it
was a departure from Max Payne which at
that point they had already given up to
Rockstar and it was something different
but it's not again and just because it
was an exclusive on that platform people
sort of associated with it but it Max
Payne and if you look at Alan wait
and I shout out to somebody mentioned in
the chat it's kind of a snooze fest like
the way that game is set up it's very
moreish with like Alan Wake constantly
talking you know and breaking the fourth
wall and sort of talking about stuff
that you know what he's doing
specifically it's a the game is set up
in a certain way that it isn't
necessarily super exciting for its time
I thought it was cool I never finished
it and I don't know man like I just
don't if they want to make it again and
reboot it now they have that opportunity
to do it I know Microsoft probably just
looked at it and was like you know what
well because I think there was plans for
two at some point and that got scrapped
but they were shopping
it was shopping multiple people with and
I did anybody who's interested outside
of mattress Microsoft as well this one
breaks our Microsoft on Remini that's
that's the real question
what I asked him seemed to come after
right because it was always perfect and
they kind of got back in the table with
quantum break and they you know he did
something but it was a good port so
another conversation that's going on is
should Sony capitalize on this and just
snap them up and take write and try to
buy remedy that's an honest with you
that might be what's going on behind the
doors because all of a sudden all these
rumors that they're gonna buy remedy and
the before you know what Microsoft's
like will so the IP back like maybe you
know that was one of the conditions it's
like if you were if we'll let you by us
if you help us by that I mean friends
don't you think like I know remedy got
money but they got that kind of money
like
I don't know I mean like oh yeah we are
going with it you know with the whole um
Alan Wake as a title I get it I just
like again for me it's optics manages
struggle with this stuff man and I'm not
even know Alan wait dude like I'm good
job King David in and solid red always
like addict world and I'm like you know
what I'm I'm gonna go against my wishes
I don't care about I'll wake up like
this is bull and they're like it's
nothing the game is relevant now and I'm
just like what about the addict or how
I'm not saying I get you but you know
what it is a lot of it is people
nostalgia like nothing the starter right
now is hurt because it's like oh my god
it's gonna be on somebody else's
platform right but beyond an Alan Wake
to I think the first thing we see is
some Alan Wake remastered come in to
like switch and PlayStation I see that
how he said King don't be nice all that
salt remedy was out there shredder
Microsoft should've brought the studio
took the IP fight all and sold the
studio to Sony later I get what you're
saying right and but to my own point
right maybe they saw a studio that
they've worked with in the past that's
like on the fringe because let's be real
if control doesn't make it where's
remedy really yet right remedy there
right now with control control looks
good but so did quantum break now when
it when it came out I thought quantum
break was good but there's a lot of
people that didn't like the game right
and maybe the same sour people won't
like control right I don't care if it's
on PlayStation ip's that's over there
that's gonna drown that IP out so maybe
Microsoft gave them the fighting chance
that they need because they knew they
wasn't gonna purchase them so I
understand what you're saying but
sometimes if somebody didn't do anything
wrong you you shouldn't
something wrong at him you give him the
best fighting chance to do something
right but myself even if you're not
gonna work good you have a right quit I
just wanna say cuz he's my thing I see
what you're saying and from a business
standpoint can you write right from pure
business you give a shot it doesn't do
the numbers or whatever I guess I
struggle with the fact that I see their
portfolio and the single player joint to
me is lacking you know I'm saying single
player experience is lacking and then we
always talk about the nurturing aspect
which is like if you have something
that's under your belt me an addict to
talk about this like it seems to be
consistent they had mass effect under
their belt at one point they had
titanfall under their control at one
point like these are things under their
control and my thing is for once I would
like to see something that was not a
homerun initially there was maybe like a
single up the middle that you nurturing
you stay with and develop that's gonna
keep them keep why does it be real with
you company no you go I'm just tired of
hearing seeing the same episode you know
I'm watching the same episode with their
title like something that's under a
control that may have have promised all
of a sudden as multi-player when it
comes to the whole respawn and Bioware
they miss a huge opportunities but they
miss that one remedy they write for the
remedy that maybe they saw that bread
with condom break it is like we always
put the I hope Sony buys remedy because
I think Sony can make remedy a great
studio I don't think no one can make
remedy agrees keeping a hundred like
Alan Wake was the middle of the road it
was a 60% ow like so does history like
people talk by Alan Wake was out here
halo in situations remedy hasn't been
the same since they gave up Max Payne
Polly of a game wasn't that to me either
and again if you look at my personal
view filling a game you look at the
numbers on again yeah business says it
probably didn't make sense to keep that
joint I get it I just don't like
something
and I can throw in the sunset
OverDrive's and I know it's oh and then
the rise is always these games that they
have that somehow they don't got no more
and the thing is they didn't they didn't
own the IP what they owned was the
publishing rights and obviously if you
were the only console in town that was a
because I think remedies self-published
on PC right so they were the only
console that were they were they they
published there so yeah they had they
were first in line to be able to do
whatever they wanted it and be able to
negotiate would remedy but like look
let's do something else for Alan Wake I
just for me again like for me can we get
to something that's all I'm sorry I
agree so many games that should have had
a part two
sunset overdrive tree I'm not saying
corner break me to seek okay that needs
to just say where it is you know in the
shoebox of Phil Spencer I don't know
where it is but that needs to stay there
nicely with God but you know what's
lacking with so many security you had a
good [ __ ] but I do think that you know
they should have went above and beyond
for rise that was when the the money
wasn't there you know maybe they could
do something our eyes I doubt it but you
know I think you know maybe not sunset I
would I don't I I didn't mind sunset I
just don't like a silly game like that
but it wasn't a bad game
let's talk corner break was trash as
always well let's go let's go to PDA I
felt like all of those games felt very
similar with the gameplay well that I
should say all of them felt very similar
with their own little niche of
differences and like Alan Wake they they
have this great thought process for our
franchise if they take it and they grow
with it and make it better because like
I didn't like the gunplay that much in
in a quantum break or Alan Wake I mean
Max Payne all three of them kind of felt
the same to me but Max Payne was so old
it felt good and so now it's like what
are they going to do where they're gonna
go with it
yeah I think that's the part that annoys
me the most is they make good gunplay
but somehow I don't like when sued us
backpedal like it annoys me it's like I
know you're better than this yeah yeah
that's flippin bucks I don't care about
remedy I care about the narrative and
the message that he leaves in the
community they have the resources to
stop that Nair Talk That Talk JD gave
her you gotta hurry with DJ I gotta
agree so you don't keep something just
for a visual but that was the one that
was arguing with Pratt right yes J okay
I'm all on your side
I've decided to give away a copy of dead
stranger I'm gonna release tensions that
have zero to do with it and then ask you
crazy today with this land Wow I'm sorry
I'm just saying you don't keep things
for visual sakes
if it doesn't hurt you to sell it back
you get your bread back I'm trust me I'm
pretty sure they want all the money they
can get back from remedy for the debacle
that was quantum break yeah you know
that studi they remember they opened up
Studios real movie studios
they shot full-length productions if not
oh that was the dawn really gone but
come on I thought the game was really
good if they would actually got across
the vision it's just didn't pan out cut
your losses and it's not the studio's
fault like and I'm pretty sure that Phil
or whoever was in charge of this this
move Matt booty whoever it was said you
know what they didn't do anything wrong
to us we probably failed them allow them
to go thrive I hope Sony picks them up
I hope they actually do make a game
it'll probably be max
seventy-five but I hope it happens all
right I got to point out one thing in
the chat I'm gonna give this one to you
JD because you've been toss in that
super chat fight your breath I'm gonna
give this one to you
he said recourse definitive edition was
awesome should have been really reviewed
to let people know the difference yeah I
agree with you I think we should have
got a record two to be on it's like we
gonna get one I think I gonna do that
one for some reason too yeah I thought
the game was a magnificent to me it was
me I did and asked me did I finish it
know the story to quantum I did
I enjoyed the story that time-travel
stuff and especially the way the story
ended up was very cool the the episodic
stuff the the the TV show stuff was
unnecessary and what bothered me is that
because I felt the gunplay was lacking
it made me mad that they spent all that
money on that video stuff and that that
to me is what shot down quantum break
quantum break story is definitely right
for a for a sequel and a changeup in
that gameplay will it never was so good
that I could like cuz it's the
consistency of it I never completed it
from start to finish like the the
cinematography would you say in the
graphics throughout the whole thing
mama taters game and repeat a several
hundred P that's shadows P I wrote in
the book I think the what is it oh it
was MP MP Oh Alan wait I don't
Adams Alan wait Cuba's coming hey
Spain's great in in Alan Wake Alan Wake
is greater than quantum break agree now
this well mushroom yeah yeah feel like
they make say me games yeah it's like
everything is kind of see me in a time
slowing and shifting and village that oh
that's why it's all on that part that's
yeah I have to respect from software so
much because like their games are
similar but they're so far apart at the
same time you take games like
blood-borne
compared to games like share or shadows
by twice and then Dark Souls and Demon's
Souls like they're the same for delay in
the same foundation but the insides
completely
oh no matter what is this nonsense my
chronobreak is trash when we talk about
some trash recall definitive edition oh
wow wow look I reserve the right to call
quantum break trash and say it's in the
bushes but say I like record I deserve
that okay you are you need a podcast
saying really believing everything that
you say okay yeah and I don't agree with
that at all I do get that more wrong I
guess the thing about it the optics it
regardless of how we feel about the game
is it oftentimes the optics are the
truth whatever loves it become truth
right because that's what's up front
that's what people are seeing so I mean
again it doesn't look great for
Microsoft once again let something go if
that's the way it went
yeah it doesn't look great at all it
doesn't the babies grow up solve that
colorful analogy will move so let's go
it's a king's topic surrounding project
scarlet and some things that may still
be happening so it seems like somebody
said that other week system that we was
gonna put out there wasn't really up to
snuff that's out the door but we do have
an all-digital all streaming system that
we want to work on in the background and
maybe he's the anaconda without the
district man it's you know and it's
actually a whole streaming box for those
people that actually want that and they
can get that in at a lower price point
hopefully they don't say you know here's
an anaconda at this point price point
and then bring out the Anaconda at all
digital division
tark or whatever the hell that is at the
same price point I think that will be
ignorant at some point time now to do
that happy to be cheaper um I think just
so like I just
your opinion real quick do you think
that they should make the all digital
like a Microsoft Store exclusive to not
confuse the consumer like yes like I
think when you do like all digital you
can purchase it from the Microsoft Store
get it shipped out to you they can
actually see who their clientele is with
this system and see the demographic
where it can grow from that opposed to
putting it inside a Best Buy and trying
to get it and confuse the consumer
that's outside in the stores like let's
let's go to the people that's actually
that can do that all digital stuff
because a lot of times these people with
data can see I am not familiar with data
caps because we don't have that here in
New York neither do we right so I am
insensitive to those individuals that
have this problem so if you have this
problem why would I put an all-digital
system inside your store close to you so
you purchase it you over your data caps
you yelling on Microsoft is the devil
like in school shooting I think he's
connected to superjet without the
message but I think it's why buy scarlet
when PS five has better games I don't
know I need to know well
yes so what's going on strong what's
going on with this thing man and cloud
is a cloud only so this is what I would
I read up on it looking at a very
inexpensive console is some some rumors
even have it at anywhere from $60 to 100
it's basically built very little in the
way of innards per se just just to
connect to the X cloud network maybe
have some functions in it that improve
latency to the network so so giving it
that sort of boost for people who who
again don't want to necessarily make a
big investment in this ecosystem by
buying up a console full fledge console
who maybe don't have access to buying a
console for whatever reason either
because of demographics or whatever the
amount of money they have to spend on it
so this is if this is true it is another
way besides through you know telephones
or whatnot they're gonna be able to get
people into the Xbox ecosystem into the
game pass ecosystem without having to
break the bank to get in um I think if
if this is true I think it's very
interesting simply because they're not
filled so made a statement he said I
don't see a future for us shout out the
deathsinger again good is kiss Scala is
greater than PS 5 let's be I'm gonna try
to read that other one and the fax I got
the connections King full hook me up
alright shut up addict he put it adding
y-bar scholar when PlayStation Father
has a better game and I must say this to
you Eddie you or the panel to talk
colors I only see colors um and you know
I hear you at it I don't see any
PlayStation 5 games like I don't stop I
expect you to say III get you not just
bought your loyal
you know walking JD game out here
smashing these pockets the shout-out to
JD gamer at basement radio arcade
partisan games both systems wildly
fighting off my screen the games on both
systems are the exact same with only 5%
representing exclusives and I want the
better Network they're doing this that
Phil said his message says I don't ever
see not put your box in your house and I
don't see I'm giving you choice that's
all I'm giving you choice right and
that's the message to us because again
this streaming stuff is a choice listen
guys I want you to understand this does
not represent my views but I'm gonna
read this to you
has a point here Sony is the crackhead
hook a nice truck I'm not gonna say I
understand what that mean but I'm just
gonna say I just ready I think that
forward with no chats today let me jump
it cuz I'm I think we I see what he was
going with that self I think for me it's
like it's nothing seemed like now
because like we eliminated Lockhart
right Lockhart is going now
so we did hear reports and shot the Brad
Sam's cuz he was the one that was saying
like they're so impressed with streaming
technology so now we're hearing now this
new cloud exclusive kind of box day but
let me ask you this like how would it
work like like is it like I did
too much on is it like how like a chrome
stick or something like did you hear
anything in reference to like the form
factor or holiday visit Lexington that's
what I'm very curious on the
implementation in the article mm-hmm was
that it was remember they weren't going
with the weaker system that a narrative
is gone this is on power-wise spec wise
off of a server it's equal to n akanda
right so you're not gonna take a step
back I don't know what's inside the box
is inside the box or are they putting
just the CPU and remember e or they're
putting just the hard drive because
remember the fast hard drive is what's
really getting these systems to where
they need to be because if you don't
have a solid state hard drive with these
CPUs is really not for nothing you need
that memory that the the cohesion with
the solid state hard drive memory and
the CPU operate based on what Sandy's
tell him he suggests a low-power box
that will be capable enough to allow a
player to move around in a virtual
environment but crucially game elements
like NPCs interactive most text and even
graphics won't be there
Oh grab smash no I'm this is not Brett i
sweared
deaf singer that man King beat out sold
Microsoft two to one and sale and now
Microsoft is about to get lapped by the
weaker Nintendo switch oh he is in the
building
just need something to have
for input so wouldn't it just be like
something along the lines that they
don't need to download anything when
they're streaming I mean think about it
like Netflix they don't stream any of
their video so all they need is
something for input he can so Brad Sam
gave the impression that by using for
instance I can't compare it to Stadium
and invite which stated he said
apparently that if you use stadium's
controller your input lag would be less
than with a regular controller via video
so their controllers optimized
specifically for their network so he
indicated that might be a thing it's
only based on on just input so like I
mean like Netflix and like half of the
games and like that and everyone uses
their phones just stream stuff to their
TVs now or their iPads so they're gonna
be just something for input so I don't
why it's gonna be what are they gonna
put in a box well I don't know that
again that's just a terminology that's
just been said I don't know if it's
going to be a physical box but
apparently this is some option that
they're considering as the low end as
opposed to the anaconda so I guess my
question to you guys is like what do you
think they if this is the case what do
you think price point they coming in
with this leg what you think pretty
lightweight way you think if they if
they put a box and you get a box hold on
I'm saying box with the controller 100
bucks that would be cool but like if
they're gonna go higher than that like I
think you're gonna have to do something
like whatever stadia price point is mmm
and stadia blew me away with the price
when don't get it wrong when they said
their price point I click alright so
fall you fraud's out there they didn't
click that didn't go and purchase state
it as I have replicator you're talking
about stadia is the wave and all this
other I was talking about
I actually went pre-order my dream now
after I stopped step with a bill still
with a jogger girl and I got a chance to
see what was really happening in these
gaming streets I canceled my drink while
he was there like nah this is over this
is a gun zero that was it so much my
thing is the price point has to be in
line with the lowest price point for the
streaming system that's did
an extremist system that went for the
throat and the jugular that's kind of be
out in a few is about you about to get
that stadion a second right forget it no
yeah and I want to see who really
playing on it are you almost on the
seats and that is not lattice lip
service
Disney Pete oh man they freakin crazy
what if you're right brat but at least I
can go into next gen knowing I'll still
have money in the bank
scum three you can keep your last of us
to accept who got Sammy Sammy Prescott
doing it with the five dollar super chat
a streaming only box zero cents who's
the target is it going to compete with
Apple TV Roku firestick but also play
games
if so lttp on that I mean but I think
Kings got a point though right because
like maybe that target is to stay here
that low price of entry and maybe that's
what they're using as a direct
competitor me it's possibility all right
so all right this is a family Prescott
jr. right Sammy I cannot state this
enough and I really want to be clear
when I'm explaining this to you that
streaming box is for everyone that
doesn't have a data cap okay I played
the X cloud I am Telling You like
everybody's keeps I what will irritate
me the most is people saying I'll see
input lag in the video you are under
some weird cloud but me when I touched
it I was rolling to the left rolling to
the right out everything that I was
doing I was doing it on purpose
everything that you saw was all I was
trying to break it I went in there with
with that mindset I'm trying to destroy
this I want to expose them cuz think
about it this way right if I go in there
and expose X cloud as a fraud how many
views you think that happens now when I
win they're trying to expose him as a
fraud and I failed miserably that's what
people was laughing and I'm telling them
is legit everybody here that was at e3
they they can tell you we're not lying
to you
in defense it's controlled bill still
well and he Cognos man we ask the hard
questions we're like you know what's up
with this how is this working what's up
like we really went and he answered
every question and the gameplay spoke
for itself like you really again the
environment yes semi control semi we
gotta go ahead I'm dead I got only this
one okay shout out the breath cuz it's
gotta be breakfast this is dad going
crazy he said - singing you're right you
have money in the bank because you won't
have any games to buy probably the best
give it a petty like he's bein the power
switch maybe I got the breath for
Saturday we gotta get one of those audio
things those soundboard no I know what
you say but like I said yeah definitely
control about we still have to see it
and while in a while
but for us to play it Wireless in a
datacenter that's 400 miles away and
we're actively trying to break it like
King is telling you I felt it was
extremely impressive as a first short
time will tell as we get on but yeah
we'll see what this you guys got to
understand I fill it's not joking when
he says he wants to reach to below like
it's it's how it sounds like hyperbole
right but at that you have to understand
the Microsoft as Xbox as a console as an
ecosystem has had difficulty penetrating
certain markets and it's never gonna
happen you're never gonna have a life in
Xbox console market in Japan that's not
happening you barely have an ex riving
PlayStation just moving and moving right
so how they but it's the truth they
why is it the portability right I don't
think so I just think they like the
homegrown hero PlayStation is Japanese
but are they more Japanese here we go
with the Ferrari no I'm just gonna keep
it real I'm just I'm gonna keep it real
like you know for a fact Nintendo was
there first a feat is definitely
cemented there but do we you were they
had a wack product they got a great
product and shut up for Sony for taking
of the bina axis of Champions at down in
Japan yeah like it's not really for us
though it's for everything I'm buying it
donít touch again it's not for us as our
primary kids you know we go to guess
who's taking me a little stream box
especially if it improves latency or
whatever in some way I'll be getting it
but it's not where the messaging is not
for us this is I'm trying to get
everybody come before you they say no
Russian is they saying to two billion is
hyperbole they'll Russia said those
centers potentially could reach 2
billion the service itself won't cuz
billions don't care about Xbox no they
don't but they don't need to see that's
the thing though when he says two
billion he's not talking about that
console that's what I like group of
people who want a little box under there
whatever the case may be right he's
talking about on your phone so it's what
you want it or you don't
the ease of access to it is gonna be
there and that's all they care about
access it anytime you want and then it
all it takes is that a little bit of a
push like let me see what this is
that's what about that's all they care
about sovereign this is where you're
right at right because I gotta say this
right well then they're not
understanding that you see this little
Play Store here right they want you to
hit the the whatever Microsoft little
app is Google's app can you hit that
Play Store and all the games that you
download and you play you stream
we want it to be streamed from your
phone your tablet whatever good old
Microsoft that's what billion comes in
it that granny Google doesn't care that
I I'm playing on Android whatever that
they don't care they meet you smack yeah
they'll want the mobile market but the
mobile market doesn't work film mobile
doesn't pay for game there's slo-mo clap
back half of that 2 billion playing free
games when they are full while they wait
at the doctor's office and taking the
train to work also there's definitely a
debate with this mobile market do you
mean pay for games I mean I've seen
placing a jail I can so if if the rumor
is true that they included in like a
game pass ultimate will the mobile
market pay for a subscription service to
play console quality games like that $10
to $15 yeah let me yes P cuz pity like
this is this is news I want to like I
want to get your opinion or like what do
you think
isn't the rebar I read this played it
also I was at e3 I came and said what's
up the cog after the conference it's
impressive
we aren't the target everyone else is it
has to compete against other set up
boxes so Lu Samuel Prescott 10 out of
superjet agree continue to be so you're
asking me but the streaming server
itself mobile it pay for it so being a
person that has you know an hour and a
half commute to work everyday being able
to sit on my phone and playing let's say
doing a strike or doing I like and some
type of instance you're doing something
on my phone will be fantastic but the
question is we have to see what happens
that first day because like the first
day of any big thing you're gonna have
those slowdowns so what's gonna happen
when all these things finally launch at
the same time I guess I guess my party
my question really more about the price
of entry like if are you willing to pay
a $15.00 suppose it again we're just
speculating there's no official another
but sub or something like yeah yeah
listen how many $15 subs are things that
we have right now I mean come on almost
gamer's right now that they want to play
a game they have a sub 4 mm so it's not
really a bad big of a deal and I'm
thinking about it you have Netflix which
is us up you know I have Hulu which is a
sub I have you know all my anime stuff
that's a song so it's a subsidy subs are
a thing of the now so it's not that big
a deal if you end up doing a sub now or
if you for something like this or not
but it's mobile it's gonna be worth it
listen they say nobody gonna run that's
T on a phone when they got a 55 inch 4k
TV at home
oh wait maybe you know reality is there
is gamers that will work that and it may
not be for us to hardcore ganking I'm
sorry I'm gonna give tellers dis right
tell us you got your raid team together
yet and sat in space for like 25
straight you know how you know destiny
let's keep it a buck right how many
times just sitting there in space
waiting for your team to get together so
you finally got your team together
I think first I never shows up and only
got to the boss right but I gotta go
pick my daughter up right now go as we
flying in I'm on my phone I pull over
I'm waiting for her to come out of
school and we finish that boss right
there so while we going up to the next
part I Drive to the next spot get there
and I can continue to play with you guys
finish our raid together while we're
there and I never left few guys like is
that seamless when you pick it up and
you play you get your game on
cuz it's tethered to your box that's
inside your house I'm explaining to you
like maybe it's not for you but I don't
know what type of phone you have and I'm
always assuming everybody has the phone
I have right so you got the top of the
line jump off
you got y'all gotta go to the bank real
quick I'm at the bank but these dudes
got to do the nightfall if I don't get
the nightfall done before 2 o'clock I'm
out all right deaf signify your brat
sure sony has gains but Last of Us is
over it Wow Gears of War was boring wow
that was it
gotta work God of War was boring witcher
3 is greater than horizon zero dawn when
sony's gonna make games for me xbox is
giving me what I want now who got JD
gave her I got it I got it
let me you I got you JD is rep enough I
want Microsoft to be successful but the
road to the - casual gamers is through
the heart oh yeah bill casual games to
the hardcore they should have learned
their lesson in 2013 or in marketing 101
take care of your first followers the
hardcore I a completely agree
you are a hundred percent right and
practice a hundred percent disinvesting
okay this is the part where I'm gonna
have to agree with JD game a real quick
and we have another one um JD gamer the
hardcore is definitely being looked
after because you have the hardcore
anaconda box okay not leaving the
hardcore that I'm trust and believe that
that box will be out first that box
comes out people get that box they're
happy me you gotta smiles on our faces
we post in our open employment that's to
be three right drop us some love for my
brothers all love boys a [ __ ] skull cast
in the local ad looking to brown that's
what's up yeah shut out listen I just
want to say JD um you don't have to
worry about the hawk or not be
represented at this point in time
because to be honest with you most of
the heads of Microsoft we had a debate
we talked behind the scenes most of the
heads of Microsoft were actually true
gamers so they represent the hardcore so
I don't ever see that leaving because
then they will be like cutting off their
arm they wouldn't want that to leave no
yo and hey I gotta get this one and when
I see music so I would follow he said yo
I had a co-worker spend a thousand or
clash of the Clan a free gay free mobile
girlfriends
60 bucks everybody buy and if they into
something and again it might not be us
right now go saying King like we say us
off yeah this generator probably that
doesn't translate to us the Hakka gamer
but there's a huge generation as playing
fortnight on a fold as playing this game
that a lot of people don't realize is
this is the casual market people don't
buy games like that like they think
that's normal just pumping money into a
game like that the thing is I think
don't get a twist I think some people
may misunderstand what we're saying and
thinking that we're talking about actual
mobile games
yeah I'm sure at some point that's gonna
be part of their strategy if if you know
X cloud on phones moves the way they
wanted to I'm sure of that but it's
about extending the hardcore experience
right it's about the hardcore and again
people who don't have access to that
hardcore console to be able to access
hardcore core experiences let me ask you
guys a question cuz that to leave here
in a second do you guys think there's
you know that huge narrative going that
I see breath you know he said let me
find that comment that's not it
mobile is free-to-play plus micro
transactions do you think that just
because it's free means that they can
validate making so free-to-play where
you have to pay money to really play the
glisten listen my wife is addicted to
Harry Potter
there Harry Potter game out and she
constantly yells and complains that
there's parts of it she cannot complete
unless she pays for it and I call that
total and complete BS vase if you're
gonna put out a free game you should be
able to complete everything for free if
you're required to pay for stuff they
never admitted I remember there used to
be some kind of a Marvel Alliance game
on Facebook as a facebook where as like
three VIII's you could play Co you can
already the ED they would give you the
opportunity to buy to to buy the
character upfront where you would have
to do this side mission and it's a long
side much like 28 steps and I remember
the last one was always you had to have
like weird care because I didn't have so
I was like the Gold's going on that way
like everyone the goats on
well they starting to do stuff like that
in regular games too or because vision -
just came out and they brought out their
fourth specialization and you can do
like these these five different specific
things and then in each of those five
things there's a whole bunch of things
you do and one guy in my clan was like
dude I'm just buying the game the game
the free year because you know what this
is gonna take me four or five hours I
don't want to do that and then in
destiny now shift in a model right with
the free-to-play basically new light and
then it can only take me access to base
game up to a certain amount of
expansions and then you pay a la carte
for what you want so in a sense they all
but I want to get back to something that
Brad said real quick I gotta take off
the chat was arguing uh you know thanks
JT gamer singer uh who's definitely pre
shout out the prep but I'm team JT gotta
go so like like what about the point
brows making that he's saying like you
know we really can't compare that with
the mobile Walker because those are
basically free games but
microtransactions whatever most of the
game so far for console is not the
opposite kind of well I think it that's
not exclusive to that they are but the
vast majority of things you're gonna
find on a Google Play Store or Apple
Store it's gonna be that right it's
gonna have some sort of some sort of
free-to-play option and then with micro
transaction is if you want to advance
that's but again when we're talking
mobile we're not necessarily talking the
mobile gaming market we're not talking
mobile games necessarily like I said at
some point I think they do sort of try
to address that because if you're trying
to bring people into your ecosystem any
way shape or form you want to do it
you're gonna have to give people variety
now everybody cares about a triple-a
experience on the phone I would like to
see what that is we know we got that
yeah I'm just saying in the long term
when you think about what you want to do
with game pass ultimately what you want
to do with X cloud right maybe to
bring people into your ecosystem is not
trying to force the core games on
everybody because not everybody cares
about the core games and I know it's
gonna piss off the core gamer because
you'd be like oh you're not caring about
us where's my single-player experience
my 50-hour single-player experience
where is that and that is a valid
argument we have yet to see any of that
we have yet the fruits of that so we
can't but iced tea wrap boy I see brats
point because we haven't seen it yet but
hopefully we will see it but I think
again when you talk about what he's
talking about these two billion gamers
yes it sounds like hyperbole but the
plan is in place and all and it requires
all of those different types of games
for it to actually happen but I might be
watching please hit that like oh yeah
sovereign right okay I hear what you're
saying but I already see the setup like
I know the fastball special is coming
right and when he says all right the
first pillar to this thing to set
everything up was we have to bite the
bullet and every first party game we put
out in-game pass right so now you're
talking about triple-a titles that's
going straight to game pass day and date
at a drive right like we got your
Twitter so at the same time everybody
was yelling out cuz you know the
naysayers yelling oh they don't have any
studios so who the hell wants the
hamburger fries and shake what was
Cognito says right with the halo the
fours and again who wants tag you know I
want diversity 15 studios now they're
going to produce games those games are
going to go to game pass now this is the
pillow where the cloud comes in you got
this cloud thing that's tied and I'm
pretty sure they're gonna tie it to your
ultimate game pass right because if they
try to push to the house the ultimate
game pass is there tied to that you have
me download because I have game pass on
my phone so now I hit my app I'm playing
cloud games whatever through my phone my
triple-a titles the horror core is being
appreciated here this stuff is bringing
it did like taking our ark and they're
putting everything together you just got
to see the building box being built I
understand everybody wants stuff now
we're living in the now world you want
stuff right now you want game has to be
great right now you want Microsoft to
have these studio you want to buy a
studio in the games tomorrow
I favor you guys that's not how it works
mm-hmm so we have to see like the value
in game paths we have to see the value
in the cloud we have to see the value in
the strategy strategy it is not
overnight you don't topo a kingdom
overnight and they're trying to topple
the best listen there's a lot I've been
seeing the chat is a lot a game pass
negativity going on they said it's a
cop-out they're saying it devalues Xbox
games in general saw for what do you
have to say because isn't it's a your
topic in reference to game packs well
this that's the funny thing because the
tie my topic is um eurogamer's article
where they spoke to developers about
what they thought about game paths right
and how game passed i the benefits or
doesn't benefit the developer and you
know they were talking about what they
feel about subscription services right
so as a gamer right we look at that and
we say look game pass as a value as a
game as somebody who's invested in Xbox
ecosystem as a value you can't Disney
it's not too much negative you can find
with it if not somebody who wants to buy
every single game that comes out day and
date whether it be you know third-party
stuff whether definitely first party
stuff will it be smaller um you know
indie stuff game pass is that a game
pass gives you all that rolled into one
and now with ultimate okay JD game with
two dollars sad fate you may X cloud
part of game pass and stadia is done
that's what we've been hearing we've
been hearing stuff ain't a from the
beginning it does it would not make any
sense to not just roll X cloud into past
without adding an additional cost
Internet into game path ultimate not I
doubt it'll be base game pass but
impasse ultimate definitely right so so
I guess thing is gamers
much negative that you can see there
everything can always improve right and
and we can talk about what things we can
see in-game past improving even more for
the game developer so the interview they
spoke to a couple of different
developers they spoke the one of the
guys who who was the founder of play
dead they spoke to a couple of other
people and they had differing views on
what game pass is to them a and B
generally what they felt about this the
description model and it's very
interesting because for instance one of
the guys who was uh one of the
cofounders of play dead obviously they
had limbo they had inside so they have a
very close connection to Xbox and Mike
right and so his experience from the
jump is that they were very much
nurtured from the beginning so he
doesn't have much negative to say about
it and for him as somebody who's coming
out with an idea and a game that nobody
had seen before for him and and if you
look at their games they're very you
know in a q8 when those games are pretty
insane like those games are pretty
tightly excellently made game so for him
he stated like the walled garden of
Microsoft and sort of that more
stringent QA process and cert process
was beneficial to his game like Hugh
enjoys it and of course there's no there
wasn't any specific talk about what
contracts they had but the money was
right for them right the money was great
for them whatever that deal was it was
right for them now you have other
developers who were talking about well
my game my game is a game that people
tend to play for thousands of hours
right so it doesn't necessarily benefit
me to get some money in front when
somebody else and they they specifically
used um not stadia they use either like
Gaikai or um what's my call it the old
thing that the King and I used to play
they specifically spoke about how our
live offered them and again the I forget
the name of the developer they were
talking about a game
like these these are TS sort of like a
sieve game or something like that if
people tend to play for hours and hours
on end
apparently online promised them money
based on the amount of time people here
and with their game I think that's
beneficial to them because of how much
time people spend with a game so it's
very interesting that people have
different views generally on on what
these subscription services can offer
you and on the dev side I think if
people are are weary unless you've been
in bed with Microsoft from the jump and
you really invented been a beneficiary
of what you know ID at Xbox is and what
game pass has been from the very
beginning it's you have to really sit
down and chop things up money wants to
see if it matters to you because a lot
of people's reservations are ok I sell
my soul to the devil upfront for 10
million dollars that I may not get when
my game hits the market especially if I
put it out on the PC market where it
could get pirated or you know so making
it through the console sort of protects
me a little bit but what happens when a
I want to have control of how I talk to
the people that play that game and it's
not on my platform and I have to go
through an intermediary which is would
be the Xbox and game pass to sort of
talk to my - to my base and then beat
what happens in three years or four
years when they've moved on to the next
big thing am I gonna get the same what
can I do if my game just sort of stuck
in limbo yeah absolutely absolutely all
right what do you want no no this is
where I feel that I can answer those
questions if if I was in you know ahead
of Microsoft on getting you to sign up
you trying to sign up right like I'm
talking to you as a developer right he
asking me all these questions you have
all these fears well um when games are
released in game paths you get an alert
on your phone and you get alert on your
xbox these are the games that came out
new this week and you can try these
games out like I told you I just try
battle chasers out and I was so hyped
for battle chasers before it got
announced to come in the game passed and
I was so elated that it did come out for
getting passed now that is in game past
the level of engagement Microsoft can
see what a game
wallets in game paths now some games
leave game paths up while other new
games come in you won't always have the
same exact game so I believe after that
period of time that your game is inside
game pass then you can do what you gave
it as you choose you can monetize it
sell it for cheaper you can get it to it
any way that you can but I believe that
the game Pass gives you a marketing
platform that you would not otherwise
have had you been a developer who didn't
have this Avenue with this big machine
behind you
show me me impasse and real quick it
just immediately once it's in game pass
you automatically millions of people
have access to it yeah okay so basically
I guess or what I'm looking at a chat
and a lot of people seem to be concerned
about the back end about what's really
happening so again I guess we trying to
talk about what the argument for putting
it on it in King's point is saying okay
if you're a smaller or not even if
you're just a game that you want
visibility and you want engagement and
the fact that you put it in this service
that millions of people have access to
for a dollar whatever it is and now
they're playing their game with are in
your online community that immediately
boosts your actual visibility kind of
what you say so as a post like for
example like a steam store right if you
just sell your game to a regular online
storefront you're hoping that it would
get on that front page right you're
hoping it'll pop right in fact it's like
a boom here's that possibility now we
have seen instances right with like a
state of decay and a sea of thieves that
the minute it went in game past they
actually won MPD and I kind of blew us
away at that point time people were
thinking hey if it's in-game pass aren't
the game out the developer losing out
because they're kind of giving it for
free and what we were told to believe
it's about shout out they are my
piscatella from MPD it really is
engagement the fact that more people
have access to it and more people are
playing the data shows it generates and
drives the shot that Bradley is actually
saying my point right now so far other
data shows that game pass drives a
player engagement which has helped
increase sales for those games and also
give games longer labs LEDs from a sales
perspective so again for those worried
about the back end they have data
to support this so this is not doom and
gloom taking these wild risks for games
to put it on I mean now some people they
may not think it's benefit some devs
maintain I think it's beneficial may not
want to do it but the option is damned
from what we've seen so early it's been
beneficial for somebody's wins but when
you would like state indicate when it
went live your access to everything or
to the or yeah no restriction the only
thing I would say is like okay if there
was like a limited edition of a game
you're not getting the limited edition
and I'd like commit you are but an
ultimate know when you got gears
ultimate when Winnett annealed that big
package all that stuff is available and
I thought it was a hustler like listen
let me let me tell you in the beginning
I was like oh man they put the the Forza
in and it didn't have this if you had
brought the special package I was like
okay so when they dropped the DLC for
the joy you can't had it I see it now I
see the hustle but then when they did
this ultimate switch right now that
house was gone like and I said okay
right but for individuals I want all you
guys watching wheel
oh you're watching this podcast cuz you
play games right you see that arcade
machine over there we all play games
alright so when somebody tells you I'm
going to give you 200 games for 15 bucks
I'm not saying that dollar crap because
that dollar crap is not a real thing
it's not real I'm gonna keep it a buck
with you fifteen dollars
I'm gonna give you 200 games a month now
you're not taking all those games when
you leave we break up and take my stuff
back
alright you coming in the door with what
you got I'm taking it back
we break up the prenup that's right so
you upset and I can see you guys upset
you upset because you don't get a chance
to keep the cookies after you lead the
relationship don't need the relationship
stay there
you know it's cheaper to keeper stay
you're behind right there play your game
a game about choice man I think it's an
excellent point he said I've definitely
board games that were in game past so
they have made sales based on my
description the problem trying to make
is this thing about this right we all
know first party Microsoft exclusives in
it right
the Halos before those are big games
that normally you would pay $60 for you
know cuz you love the franchise whatever
and that's day and day in game pass the
question the thinking people gotta think
about also is like the same title like
that now you have a below or mutineers
zero a game that you may be interested
in but to yourself like paying $60 you
can't afford it now that it's in game
pass and it's literally on the same
level as these other games that's what's
getting people to engage in games that
they may not have otherwise bought that
for straight of cash that's another
reason and again the data supports it
companies are not going to do something
if it's not beneficial for them that's
just a fact they're not gonna if they're
not making any money off it they're not
doing it so again like for the people
concerning about the back end these guys
have the numbers they have and again
we've had and I'm gonna bring Matt back
on the show by the way I'm gonna have
piscatella name because we got it a lot
of people too worried about Microsoft
pockets and the developers pockets these
are statistical numbers that they have
access and they are privy to and they're
seeing benefit from it so we have to
respect that aspect is that uh feel like
like like like Jedi fall in order
there is no you're gonna see that in
game past if you do I'll be a hell of a
prize to night in game passes the EA
game but like those types of games that
have those big backings yeah I don't
think you're gonna see those our picks
are proud of someone a big I mean we
just know Wolfenstein in that case goes
to the other point right what can we see
obviously impasse is a great value for
the gamer
what what do they need to do to continue
to improve it especially when we've
always talked about hey you don't have
to party stuff day and date right
it's the epic game store and addicts
favorite is to go oh
they pay for stuff attic something you
have to do I have a couple minutes for
us to take it back off I just took a
shower and got back on but um
I think what this this if for those
either can't see because you can't see
the chat on the right I was like let's
talk about the cloud stuff last because
I want really talk about that that's all
Kings and there's Lane I don't care
about it I played it and I thought it
was good and I was a believer in that
form but I want to talk about this game
fast because I honestly feel like the
only thing that's stopping this from
pushing it once
if obsidian undead if all of them start
popping out decent quality games or good
good quality games that's all it's gonna
tell you because people are going to get
this service for $10 a month because
they're gonna buy more Microsoft games
naturally because they're getting better
and all the third party stuff for indie
stuff thrown in from sprinkles is just
going to be a be points to David yeah I
got a jumpin I've just about to mention
Metro Exodus another thing I can third
party game fantastic at launch right now
in-game pass not think about it that
game technically is at the end of its
cycle in as far as retail so it's in
there all in there too and it's like
boom so now you've added this extra
level of engagement and I pretty much
every but as the games in there a most
legit game so again another way that I
can see devs using it is again through
the normal MPD cycle right they after
that month or two months of games at its
peak right now you on the backend now
the money slowing up and let's let's
give it to Microsoft for a good check
you know I'm saying that that's what
people do I mean that's just part of it
extending that it extends the life on
the widow I've been seen before like you
know you know what's really missing to
make game pass really take off if they
had a game that's on like the caliber
that overwatch got to know like you
don't like a vector like that yes
something no not even apex that's free
to play but you know what you know what
it is is gonna be the bleeding edge
hopefully like I I really enjoy bleeding
edge I got some issues with some things
but you know it is the beta or they out
for whatever they want to call it that's
what's funny is kid Smith was trying to
get one and I was like well I don't know
it's the plate can't don't play office
they don't pay him
he goes what's up with that bleeding
that you're gonna play it so I said oh
my book bag is up an attic look at the
exact words it's like are you have you
downloaded I didn't do that but that
game I think and I was sitting there
talking with um Nina and I honestly I
didn't think that Microsoft showed it in
his best light right and she was taken
aback when I said that but I was being
honest because when I saw it I was like
oh and just like that I was like and I
knew it when I said it on the show I
said oh this is their little stepchild
that they trying to get out there they
went the world of see it
boom boom bang then I saw the game
physically when my eyes actually playing
I saw the animation on the characters I
saw the level of detail on the
characters so when I see games like that
of that nature I like I think of
overwatch and I think of all these
cartoon type of games that give you a
rich character with rich history and
give you give you a little something
that you can fall in love with the
character you can feel great about it
that's what apex did for me now the guns
what an apex made it also greater games
crazy when I play bleeding edge it was
it felt like Power Stone and like she
said it's Power Stone on mega steroids
and it felt different fun fantastic and
I said Microsoft's own one and I don't
know why they didn't show it in this
proper light because the game look light
years ahead of what I saw on the screen
playing it when you guys get a chance to
get it in game pass that it launches in
game pass a game that you'll probably
say I'm not gonna buy that but isn't
game pass so go try that all right
PlayStation guys who have an xbox and
they're trying games just because
they're in game pass and again you know
zeroes in game pass I highly suggest if
you like XCOM play that it's come on the
switch it's good it's coming on the
switch it's past week I try it out
Boyd bastards and the outer wilds just
cuz it was oh I hate that daggone games
oh god oh my god is not a game for you
outer worlds like you let me download
this right now before t take it off
he said void bass is legit witty with
that straight is definitely not a king
it's the slow plotting it's a garbage
game that needs to just get off again
but it sees games like that doesn't game
pass are we saying yes right yo i'ma
tell you right now I can guarantee you
is 91 people right now go to your game
past download download that outer worlds
CB next go out of whatever the hell is
door [ __ ] go going down look it's the
only one in there with the out of name
go to here download it and then come
back and tell me how you really feel on
a serious note man there's 90 people in
there give it up that's random from IGN
she tweeted them and she is like oh I
loved outer worlds that I was I was
straight-up jealous cuz I thought it was
that one I was like man how do I go like
this she play this like three or four
month war comes out
it's a difference is out a world that is
out of wild so we need to actively get
together and throw it back in are you
saying that that it's like there's
bushes at the bottom you're falling if
you're falling towards the bushes and
you call game paths you can you can
avoid going into push whoa listen that
don't need to avoid to go it need to get
to double bushes I need to get the
bushes and shrubs basically to close it
out I just really think the game pass
obviously the values there for the game
aright and I totally agree that the fact
that what-what addict said is is really
on point as these first party Xbox
studio start getting their games out Oh
hold up scammer by choice with the
twenty dollar super check thank you for
fun intelligent discussion of gaming I
love gaming and I love this channel I
learn and laugh so much iron Lords are
awesome keep up the great work thank you
appreciate people who there's people in
the chat that have said you guys laugh
more than any other podcast I've ever
seen so for me it's just to me obviously
game paths can always get better like
what I said at some point maybe looking
at you know third-party exclusives and
trying to open that bag and see what
happens there but I think in the long
term when these Microsoft Studios start
getting the games out we have a more of
a release cadence emotive obsidians
games coming out the end of your own
game packs like you have exact comment
on game past but it is coming out for
everybody else so right but I wanted to
get that because that has nothing to do
with the service itself even if those
cross those multi plat
for example outer world
we know that's coming to the PlayStation
mostly gone game has the fact that its
in-game pass just for the fact that at
that low entry point
what's feeling to you financially as a
game right you know give makes sense you
know I'm saying the same thing the last
thing I want to jump in before I forget
is that I definitely don't want to under
understate ultimate right because
ultimate is a tremendous package yeah
you get those those hateful I get a play
for days sooner if you have all times
I'm thinking about about snow though I'm
like he's PC master-race
right gets game pass ultimate he's got
the entire library Microsoft does not
care where he plays as long as he's in
their ecosystem he does not care how it
played state of the K together again on
these things that again people might not
normally try from Xbox or buy on their
own but because of that service that the
point of entry is so low like why would
you not try it you know I'm saying that
content and their whole thing is yo if
you try it he might end up liking it and
then look yeah he names like see if
these making resurgence is and stuff
like it happens they want engagement
because reasons I like moonlighters is
because someone was playing it on game
pass and told me about it and you know
shoutout to John big guy John yeah he is
not he's not on the game pathway he does
not like a little bit he's a but you
don't get triple-a multi-platinum and I
was like look man there's so like what's
what he's all it's like we're we're
surrounding him all of our other friends
like my real-life friends like they know
him like what we're surrounding
enclosing him it was a game pants game
he's just like look if I want the game
I'll buy it
he's like but you're not buying some of
these games because you're not looking
for them but they just show up and the
beauty about game passive I'll be
playing again like what's that oh my
dude I actually like its own game pass
like you can't have that conversation on
played stage is
not even a PlayStation vs Xbox thing
this is its its value like the topic is
the value of game pass I don't know
where you get a better value for your
dollar outside of video games it has to
be something like Hulu it has to be
something like Netflix you have to talk
about streaming services of videos to to
even compete with this level of service
that they're giving you now when you're
gonna sit there telling me oh but third
party games are launched third party
game so I think we're gonna see a lot
more I think what we're seeing now in
game pass is like the sprinkle gank pass
I think that you know that they're
getting all their lines or figure out
how game pastors they want it to
function and then when next-gen starts
that's what you're gonna see the game
pass they envision right make it a point
to counter you say like Xbox exclusive
game quality's all that matters at the
end of day game pass whatever X cloud
whatever console power whatever quality
triple a game with a year tile I agree
with that now here's the thing I feel
what you're going with that big house at
the end of the day kind of erratic to
saying if it does get to that quality
right if it does as we don't you manage
them all on Last of Us if it does how
tremendous even more with the value be
so again you know am I gonna stop
telling someone to pay for a service
that they can get that low cost to entry
when people hear struggling for jobs and
financially the old stuff I know people
that say y'all wouldn't even bought an
Xbox if it wasn't for that I know people
like you know snow I mean I saw the Thom
potentially perfect he was like you know
I bought it because he gave us he's like
that it was too good to not do it
shoutout to meds you know sucks the
gears he he's on an X he bought an X and
he don't buy games for the Xbox cuz he
just gets game passed like we regardless
what people want to come out here you
know say this hash to Xbox stench like a
game pass is the real thing it really is
like a boy he's like it's a wall for
ultimate 400 when the basic night max
got all the bats he said ain't no damn
first party games from Microsoft they
only got 10 exclusive say yeah we got it
what
with funnies microsoft owns more studios
and Sony now you know what I feel and I
like the crossover that you're doing
right now because you looking like Allen
Iverson oh hey and I'm gonna have to get
the fraud like do you do my friend with
a 1 out here talking about Xbox this and
Xbox that you my friend actually out
here we're airing Greenberg heating
systems and they treat you great that
you my friend is that fan fest and all
that so there's Sony's switch up stuff
people right now this crossover stuff
listen I love you brother but I'm gonna
tell you right now game passes that real
thing and you know it stop playing now
you're upset that ok yo didn't show me
what I wanted to see but you're gonna
get what you want soon you know you will
be the same switchover crossover do
comment September when their gears come
out and you playing it for free let me
take care of this bill let me take care
of all this is great let's not forget
that do you agree with justice said
there in that super check well I miss
native fax I mean really just look at it
what stitch stated is the fact that Sony
doesn't have any security we all know is
a free fall feel cache of over there we
know that but that's what they guys they
got those old trucks they don't have a
back to itself just falls out on top but
yeah you know what it is don't you see
what y'all not understand it is Sony
really doesn't want you to do the
multiplayer thing they giving you a
single-player experience they don't
really want you to get on the internet
because they know these securities bad
so they giving you these single-player
game so you don't have to interact with
the rest of the community in the corner
with no internet just be given that
single play experience you don't discuss
everything else about this exactly
playing games like talk about you know
what this sound quality or let's get on
disc or do you did you feel except when
Forza horizon was on game pass did you
feel upset are you gonna feel upset when
gears come out and is on your game pass
are you gonna feel upset when the
exclusive titles come out and his long
Guinea pass did you feel upset when um
what was that um that blade game from
these guys from Ninja Theory
hell blade was you upset when that came
out in game past I mean I really want to
understand why you truly upset with
somebody that's actively begging for
your love now you're talking about the
other dudes over there with the no
security they say hey come over here
they don't really care about you at all
they're not giving you anything but
you're saying oh but they got good games
okay so by both your gamer by both and
there you go that's game of talk that's
game of talk anyway we got on this man I
think at the end of the day I think
Microsoft was gonna keep improving game
passed for gamers and I think they're
gonna keep improving the reasons why
dubs should come to that platform I just
think it's it's smart on their part and
I think they're real cognizant of what
they have to do to make that the place
to go so I see it improving on both ends
of the spectrum
and that's what we got that's what we
got today I hope you won 16 big shout
out to the track you guys are beyond
late today
you guys know shout the Fonz the ground
a game of a man and of course big shout
out to Pete
aka Lords now though good morning we
sandwich them in this oh no dude no
Chris right now Chris you want to show
up now at the end of the job Chris I
knew you was a PlayStation got hacked
what guys I had to come rent we
appreciate that so much got a couple of
videos coming up for ILP first looks if
you guys want to check that out um Oh
got another one jaded you want to take
care of that yjd game again with the
files which have real question for the
panel is can Microsoft improve their
marketing and their now word after that
if they're launching this this online
only console they have to make sure that
message is out there that people don't
get confused and they need to fix that
I'm compromised here in purchase I was
in purchase I've been sold so JD I
couldn't really answer their question
because me answering that question will
undermine my are my new control panel
answer that and obviously microscope is
doing a bang-up job in a market
everything and on twitch five nights a
week Monday to Friday 7:00 to 10:00
Eastern and most of the division stuff
and and that's and discord if you guys
hit up on discord that's fantastic if
anyone is thinking about joining the
stream team or is looking or know
somebody that is a streamer that would
like to join up just have them send me a
DM in discord and will review that
application and then we will go forward
with that
doubt um one other thing just give a
brief little quick overview of that that
that gleam IO giveaway that's coming oh
yes the gleam I'll give away is it is
concluding midnight next Saturday
so everyone make sure you get in on
those after that your tickets will be
reviewed and then after that the next
ILP Sunday around this time you will
know who won that uh Marvel this [ __ ]
so your NTSC only NTSC only verify that
no doubt thanks a lot Lord people coming
through appreciated cause you guys had
me on King what do we have we I know we
have some statute stuff coming was good
all right so you know we got stuff we
got we got I got a bunch statutes on oh
and I'm gonna give you the new schedule
now if you watch the last video I told
you that the next statue is gonna be
somebody that is hard to kill and I have
people hitting my inbox up like who
talking about this dude nothing I got it
right so when you see it you're like
whoa that was fantastic
also arcade talk you know there's an
arcade with the King King arcade that's
coming as you can see that system right
there has over six thousand nine hundred
games and shout out to Lord Cognito for
getting me my capture device so I'm able
to implement that so I'm I'm playing
around I'm looking with it I'm trying to
learn certain things that techniques the
format will change with king of the
statues and combat talk with the king is
coming up you have packed up purses
Thurman whoa I'm gonna miss it now what
I'm gonna do is something a little bit
different with this right here because
this is a mega fight sometimes you
didn't think was not happy
you didn't think Pacquiao will get in
there with that young lion and you
didn't think that young lion will take
that challenge because we can say that
there was an on a collision course but
it happened so I'm gonna give you a
fighter breakdown on Pacquiao just all
Pacquiao edition then I'm gonna give you
a fighter breakdown and a synapses on
our key Thermage so you can get the
background of these fighters and you can
understand what they're up against and
what they're trying to achieve and
what's next for these fighters and then
I'm giving you the breakdown of the
when the fight is about to happen after
the weigh-in guys nice we also go back
to the boss Lord cockney know what's
going on looki after I was forcibly
posted I'm chilly I like this guest I
can only do salut you our [ __ ] this man
one week feels crazy being honest two
weeks for me man just felt weird it was
good to be back on absolute fun and
around realm always showing love PD hold
it down you already know stream to shout
to dizzy Lords gaming that net we got
some stuff coming up and check out more
Guardian con coverage I'm gonna be
putting up we got tons of stuff trying
to get I'm gonna call it like the walk
with me series King yo shadow I want you
to understand something real quick this
stuff is coming out of our pockets acts
like this man just got back from
spending some G's going to California
it's been some more going up Guardian
for the love of this game right now was
really nuts and I'm looking at the views
on the video and in and I don't see
nobody at Guardian come on alright
posting videos so he's posting these
videos I give it a look even if you
don't like destiny like he told you it
is other games there so please give it a
look leave a comment down at the bottom
because we definitely answer your
questions and I have a bunch of
questions for them anyway off here cuz
this is the first time I get a chance to
talk to him okay yeah man just for the
love you know say as a gamer you know me
I do my pilgrimages you know saying I do
my little travels but now this is
something I've been following a long
time they grown we got something else
there all the laws including cooking up
that we're gonna do for y'all on the
realm and um I can't wait to show y'all
that and that's something that we think
is gonna potentially grow into something
special we can't talk about that just
yet but what it happened in about a
month
we will disclose that you know I'm sayin
but yeah thanks King I really meant a
lot cuz I it's fun it's fine to go out
there yes man when I saw you anybody
city
one big look at your head look at this
it's just like God what are they doing I
gotta I gotta bring people to the water
so they could drink oh we've got a baby
gotta show them with the waters nice
some late-night activities but you
really bad for you shout out to so many
people like I get like you gotta
understand it's like Oh picture being in
like Paradise Island bro like it's like
invited up tickets are gonna be up now
the only things next year's a little
tight next to III don't see I liked it
this year because they had like a little
space July 4th weekend and then eateries
June next year they making it bigger
they're gonna have bigger game or
entities but it's like two weeks after
e3 so I think I don't we meet at akkad
he parties they came through my body cam
putting on his head so you gotta put on
his Peck cuz he just mad fine you gonna
see a lot of footage coming up stuff
like that and like I said be on the
lookout we're gonna have another special
last word this Friday so I'm somewhat so
we gonna have big guess I cannot wait
and on ILP next week we're gonna have a
develop I don't want to disclose yet
we're trying to finalize the details it
may be
special time I'll get back to you guys
on that but an up-and-coming developer
all I will say it was on the mark so
stage and um it's a great story so I
will get back to you guys once we
finalized and that's all I got man soft
thank you for holding it down brother
King thank you falling it down attic
snow gonna cool you already know much
love it man so for me of course Lord
sovereign and the offline profile
Illuminati who lives the single-player
self is experience the holster Thomas I
like that I like that I can rock with
that though I hate hosting but I can
ride well you guys that Lord South IOP
and being sovereign on PSN xbox live
real quick one thing that I didn't
mention that I was planned and nobody
talked about yo that samurai shodown yo
King when I tell you they brought back
the love no no no that was that was
something that was some you know the ps4
or whatever that I laid in for lag is
fantastic is beautiful oh cool love so
I'll talk a little bit more about
samurai showed up next week but again
big shout-out to the chat big shout out
to everybody we've set out to cog for
having faith in me and holding us down I
told them we need a patreon tier just
for him and adding just to go that's the
day to dial please over cuz you gotta be
some like bearded brothers in the night
we got everybody enjoy the rest of your
Sunday once again thanks a lot for
coming through peace